nous allons pouvoir commencer nous vous
prions de vouloir nous excuser pour le
petit
décalage dû à des questions logistiques
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'auditionner ce matin les
représentants de l'Observatoire de la
parentalité de l'éducation numérique
open représenté par son directeur
fondateur Thomas Romer accompagné
docteur en psychopathologie psychologue
clinicienne et 100 psychologue
spécialisé dans les problématiques du
numérique et des usages du jeu vidéo
grâce à votre réseau d'experts votre
association dispense des formations à
l'éducation numérique à destination des
parents et des professionnels en contact
d'enfants comme vous le rappelez je vous
cite entre naïveté quand un impact des
applications et panique morale être un
parent ou un adulte en contact d'enfants
ou d'adolescents demeurent compliqués
jusque là je pense que
tout le monde est d'accord où mettre le
curseur quel cadre à partir de quel âge
quel risque comment les accompagner ces
questionnements s'appliquent
probablement également à Tik Tok
application qui comme nous le savons
maintenant et massivement plébiscité par
les adolescents je citerai trois
chiffres particulièrement
impressionnants que nous avons ressorti
70% des utilisateurs de Tik Tok en
France aurait moins de 24 ans 40% des 16
25 ans sont sur Tik Tok chaque jour
enfin les quatre 18 ans passent en
moyenne près de deux heures par jour sur
l'application ce succès chez les
adolescents et même chez les très jeunes
enfants puisque un tiers des cinq sept
ans utiliseraient également
l'application pose de nombreuses
questions
nous nous interrogeons sur les
conséquences de cette utilisation
intensive éventuellement sur la santé
mentale le développement cognitif ou la
réussite scolaire des jeunes au delà des
effets qui sembleraient être connus sur
les autres réseaux sociaux nous
souhaiterions savoir si Tik Tok amplifie
ou pas ses effets ici il y a de votre
point de vue une spécificité propre à
l'application qui pourrait être liée
d'une part à l'algorithme dont on nous a
souvent venté l'efficacité mais aussi à
une utilisation qui serait
intensive et également du fait de la
jeunesse nous venons d'en parler des
utilisateurs outre le diagnostic nous
aimerions également connaître vos
propositions afin soit d'encadrer cet
usage soit de donner des clés aux
parents pour le faire et ainsi limiter
au maximum les potentiels effets
négatifs je me dois de vous rappeler que
cette audition est captée retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et avant de
vous laisser la parole pour un exposé
des mineurs si cela vous convient d'une
quinzaine de minutes puisqu'on pour
qu'on puisse garder le temps pour les
questions et vos précisions je me dois
de procéder au formalité d'usage pour
les commissions d'enquête et de vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité avec la
vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
merci bien vous avez la parole écoutant
avec attention
un monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs les sénatrice et les sénateurs
merci beaucoup pour cette invitation
Thomas Robert donc je suis le
fondateur de l'Observatoire de la
parentalité numérique je vais faire très
rapidement pour pour pouvoir passer la
parole à deux personnes qui ont eu la
gentillesse de m'accompagner ce matin
pour rentrer dans le vif du sujet
simplement rappeler que les objectifs de
cette observatoire que j'ai créé ne sont
pas uniquement que d'observer et de
faire des études mais aussi comme vous
l'avez souligné monsieur le Président
d'aller à la rencontre des parents et
des professionnels autour de ce qui est
un véritable enjeu d'éducation merci
et
l'idée de cet échange ce matin ça va
être grâce à la fois ce que nous
observons sur le terrain mais aussi les
études que nous pouvons produire mais
aussi l'expertise de Milan et angélique
qui reçoivent beaucoup de familles et
vont au contact des familles dans le
cadre de leur pratique
professionnelle d'essayer de nous
apporter un certain nombre d'éclairages
et de répondre au mieux à vos questions
et je tenais aussi à saluer Marion Hasan
notre présidente qui nous a aidé à
préparer cette audition voilà je laisse
la parole à
Angélique peut-être pour pour démarrer
sur par rapport aux questions qui nous a
été posées et commencer à dérouler notre
exposé
oui bonjour et merci pour cette
invitation à partager nos réflexions et
notre expertise au sujet des réseaux
sociaux numériques et particulièrement
de Tik Tok et de ses effets sur les
enfants et les adolescents alors on nous
intervenons en effet aujourd'hui en tant
qu'expert de l'Open mais aussi en tant
que psychologue clinicien travaillant
auprès d'enfants d'adolescents et de
famille et il nous importe vraiment de
préciser ici que notre positionnement se
fait à partir du terrain nous propose
s'appuient sur nos observations nos
observations cliniques à partir de la
parole des parents des enfants et des
adolescents des professionnels également
de terrain mais aussi des études menées
par l'Open et de nos études respectives
en tant que chercheur
ce que nous souhaitons ici apporter
c'est donc un savoir expérientiel un
teneur qualitatif et non quantitative
d'autant plus que comme la soulignait
notre collègue grégoryborse lors de son
audition il n'y a pas d'études
scientifiques notamment française sur
les effets psychiques de TikTok chez les
enfants et les adolescents
alors le premier point à avoir en tête
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le réseau social
est un objet culturel pour les
adolescents qui ne peut se détacher du
quotidien des familles et des autres
stimulations de ce quotidien à savoir
l'école les amis les loisirs etc les
usages des réseaux sociaux numériques
sont donc à rattacher au fonctionnement
plus général des adolescents et de
l'adolescence et des familles
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux dont
TikTok fait partie et donc le reflet des
vies des personnes en 2023 nombreux sont
les adolescents qui utilisent
quotidiennement les réseaux sociaux tels
que snapchat YouTube Tik Tok et
instagram sur le schéma le tableau que
nous vous montrons ici on voit bien
qu'il y a une forte augmentation de
l'utilisation de TikTok en 2022 mais il
reste associé aux autres réseaux sociaux
comme Instagram et snapchat
l'utilisation donc des adolescents de
ces réseaux sociaux est multiple et
diverses et elle vient pointer des
usages pluriels et différenciées en
fonction des plateformes par exemple sur
snapchat les adolescents vont l'utiliser
pour leur cercle d'amis assez fermé vont
utiliser particulièrement la messagerie
instantanée sur Instagram les
adolescents vont plutôt suivre des
influenceurs vont travailler la mise en
image de soi à travers les photographies
filtrées et sur TiK ToK on va avoir des
adolescents qui disent utiliser cette
plateforme pour le divertissement mais
aussi pour consommer de l'information
alors pourquoi parce qu'elle est simple
d'utilisation elle permet de créer du
contenu en s'amusant au montage vidéo et
audio une jeune fille de 16 ans dira moi
j'aime Tik Tok parce que c'est amusant
alors on ne peut pas se focaliser sur un
seul réseau social numérique c'est un
ensemble de pratiques numériques et
c'est un point essentiel à avoir en tête
mais on pose quand même une question
c'est quand même s'interroger s'il
existe ou non des réels spécificités de
Tik Tok bon Tik Tok qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est
un flux vidéo continue
c'est des vidéos sous format short d'une
durée entre quelques secondes jusqu'à
une à deux minutes
c'est pas la bonne slide
c'est aussi l'absence d'arrêt sur image
ce qui implique une lecture passive et
c'est une application qui ne propose pas
de page d'accueil
c'est aussi un réseau social numérique
qui ne permet pas de communication
directe entre les utilisateurs
utilisatrices pour les jeunes de moins
de 16 ans
c'est aussi la possibilité d'un mode
connexion famille et d'un mode compte
privé les comptes de jeunes entre 13 et
15 ans sont par défaut
mis en mode compte privé
le mode connexion famille permet de lier
de compte de au sein d'une même famille
et sur TikTok il y a la présence de défi
vidéo
et il semblerait avoir aussi une
présence plus importante d'enfants sur
Tik Tok en comparaison avec les autres
réseaux sociaux numériques
à noter que YouTube est Instagram
partage quelques-unes de ces
spécificités il y a l'onglet explorer
sur Youtube qui permet d'accéder à des
contenus sous format short
on retrouve sur ces deux réseaux sociaux
que j'ai nommé les défis en question et
on retrouve également une présence
importante d'enfants sur ces deux autres
réseaux sociaux
encore une fois
merci
donc voici une étude qui a été dirigée
par la pyrule Center en août 2022 qui
est intitulé teans
était un centre de recherche un think
tank américain qui fournissent qui
fournissent des statistiques et des
informations sociales
l'objectif de l'étude était d'analyser
les habitudes et les pratiques
d'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
numériques
chez les adolescents de très à 17 ans
sur un échantillon de 1500 03
5002 adolescent
âgés
les tunes interrogées la fréquence la
durée de cette étude de ces utilisations
du type de contenu qui sont partagés ou
utilisés de la priorisation des réseaux
sociaux numériques chez ces jeunes et de
noter également aussi des écarts et des
divergences des pratiques selon les
classes socio-économiques et culturelles
sur le graphique numéro 1 que vous
pouvez voir ici nous observons
l'évolution des pratiques des
adolescents entre 2014 2015 et 2022 et
ce que nous pourrons noter c'est que il
y a un accroissement de l'utilisation de
certains réseaux sociaux numériques donc
Instagram plus 10% snapchat plus 18%. et
TikTok qui n'existait pas en 2014 donc
nous ne pouvons pas observer l'évolution
de ce point de vue là mais en 2022 était
noté que 67% des jeunes sont des
utiliser Tik Tok
toujours en nous appuyant sur cette même
étude le graphique 2 indique combien
d'adolescents utilisent très
régulièrement
certains réseaux sociaux numériques
on peut voir ici que un cinquième des
jeunes
utilise YouTube et Tik Tok très
régulièrement un sixième utilise
Instagram très régulièrement et un quart
utilise snapchat très régulièrement nous
pouvons également observer que Facebook
est massivement des investis chez les
populations jeunes
ce qui est important de noter c'est que
YouTube reste de loin le réseau social
numérique le plus investi par les jeunes
aujourd'hui
voici une autre étude menée par la
commande San smithia qui est une ONG
américaine spécialisée dans l'étude des
médias et des technologies familiales
une étude menée en 2021 intitulée de
common senseus medialius by twins
qui appuie en fait les données
précédentes que nous venons de vous
montrer sur un échantillon de 13006
jeunes entre 8 et 18 ans
ce que nous pouvons observer sur ces
deux tableaux c'est que Tik Tok et le
deuxième réseau social numérique le plus
utilisé parmi les 68% d'utilisateurs
utilisatrices 22% sont certes très
régulièrement ce qui équivaut à un tiers
Tik Tok et le troisième réseau social
numérique dont les jeunes disent ne pas
pouvoir s'en passer
ce qui correspond à 13% parmi les 68%
soit 1/5
et YouTube
reste le réseau social numérique le plus
utilisé le plus populaire et le plus
essentiel dans tous les cas sur 83% des
utilisateurs utilisatrices nous
observerons 24% qui s'en servent le plus
un peu plus d'un quart et 32 % qui ne
pourraient se passer du futur
usage des réseaux sociaux numériques et
notamment de TikTok pourraient relever
de ce qu'on appelle le pharmacon c'est à
dire que possiblement il peut être
toxique mais le poison peut s'inverser
en remède et inversement le remède peut
devenir poison qu'est-ce que cela veut
dire ça veut dire que l'enjeu d'une
numérique comme pharmacon et aujourd'hui
flagrante en effet l'objet numérique qui
soit réseau social ou jeux vidéo peut
venir répondre aux attentes du sujet
l'adolescent notamment mais aussi adulte
tout en créant de nouvelles attentes
c'est bien le dosage et la quantité qui
peuvent transformer le remède empoison
un point essentiel donc à retenir et
qu'il y a des effets positifs et des
effets négatifs à l'usage des réseaux
sociaux numériques ceci est fonction de
la coloration de la vulnérabilité propre
à l'adolescence de l'environnement de
l'adolescent de son usage singulier des
réseaux sociaux et de la qualité de sa
communauté numérique
c'est l'ensemble de ces éléments qu'il
faut donc prendre en compte
les réseaux sociaux donc pourraient donc
être un remède à l'adolescence puisque
on peut se poser la question nous en
tant que chercheur depuis plusieurs
années pourquoi les réseaux les
adolescents sont autant sur les réseaux
sociaux et notre réponse c'est que ça
répond bien sûr à un besoin adolescent
le premier fondamental à cette période
c'est la socialisation les ados
retrouvent leurs amis de la vraie vie
sur les plateformes et sans créer
d'autres au sein de leur communauté
numérique cela leur permet
d'expérimenter le sentiment
d'appartenance à un groupe de pairs ce
sentiment est important à explorer à ce
moment de l'adolescence puisqu'il permet
de faire des expériences en dehors du
milieu familial en dehors du regard
parental les réseaux sociaux sont donc
des terrains numériques d'expérience non
investie par les parents ou en tout cas
différemment et les adolescents se
retrouvent entre eux partagent des
activités des langages et des centres
d'intérêt
c'est ici le processus de séparation
nécessaire avec les parents qui est en
jeu et qui va permettre aux adolescents
de se construire en dehors du regard
parental
d'expérimenter la relation à l'autre de
manière amoureuse ou amicale qui plus
est utilisé un même réseau et notamment
Tik Tok c'est véritablement se sentir
intégré à une sphère sociale partageant
les mêmes codes la même culture et le
même langage le second besoin à
l'adolescence et la quête identitaire
les réseaux sociaux numériques par la
mise en image de soi l'appel du regard
de l'autre les identifications les uns
aux autres la réflexivité qui est
inhérente à un retour que les autres ont
sur le sujet adolescent vont participer
à la quête identitaire ils vont
participer à trouver des questions
existentielles à des réponses à des
questions existentielles pardon à
expérimenter son image à apprivoiser son
image du corps à trouver
dans le regard des autres de tous ces
autres dans la communauté un regard qui
va valider cette quête du je suis qui
est le devenir de la de l'adulte ce sont
donc ces validations qui permettent à
l'adolescent de construire son identité
comme il va se tester dans le milieu de
la vraie vie entre guillemets dans la
sphère scolaire sociale des loisirs etc
c'est donc ces expériences qui vont
faire une une partie du développement de
l'adolescent bien évidemment il y a des
risques à l'usage des réseaux sociaux
numériques on en parle très souvent et
encore une fois série risque sont liés à
la vulnérabilité propre de l'adolescent
à l'environnement de cette adolescent
comment il est accompagné dans ses
usages à aux Paramètres des comptes et à
la qualité de sa communauté
les risques sont le cyber-harcèlement
qui revient de manière très première
dans les discours de tous mais qui n'est
pas non plus celui qui est le plus
important la radicalisation de la pensée
c'est à dire que les adolescents vont se
retrouver dans des communautés qui ont
une idéologie ou un mode de pensée
unique et l'algorithme va faire qu'on va
proposer la même chose et donc on va pas
forcément pouvoir aller vers d'autres
communautés d'autres idéologies les
conduitaristes avec par exemple
identification à certains influenceurs
qui prônent la chirurgie esthétique pour
pour exemple ou certains challenges mais
pas tous qui vont peut-être quelquefois
poussé à l'alcoolisation par exemple
avec les necks nomination le choc des
images visualisées qui peuvent induire
des troubles du sommeil une anxiété
modérée des complexes physiques et là je
pense particulièrement des images
pornographiques et des mouvements
dépressifs qui peuvent s'associer à des
troubles du comportement alimentaire à
des troubles du rythme nycthéméral des
troubles de l'image de soi notamment de
la dysmorphophobie mais aussi des
consommations de produits illicites mais
attention ça ne veut pas dire que s'il y
a ces risques ces risques sont liés
uniquement de manière
univoque avec une causalité directe aux
réseaux sociaux la souffrance peut être
préalable à l'usage des réseaux sociaux
et ce dernier ne sera que le reflet
d'une souffrance préexistante
pour exemple nous avons beaucoup en
thérapie des adolescents qui vont
utiliser les réseaux sociaux suite à un
vide d'existentiel ou un mal-être très
prégnant et qui vont utiliser ces
réseaux de manière excessive parce que
cela leur permet d'avoir une connexion
directe immédiate faciliter avec des
autres d'occuper son temps mais aussi
son esprit et d'évacuer les conflits
internes et les conflits familiaux il
s'agit là d'un usage refuge des réseaux
sociaux dans ce contexte d'impossible
corrélation entre souffrance psychique
et réseaux sociaux numériques toute
captation envers les réseaux pourra
interpeller les adultes que nous sommes
c'est à dire un temps disproportionné
passé sur les réseaux sociaux une
captation à des images retouchées une
attente vitale des commentaires et des
likes etc etc
on peut ici percevoir que la manière
dont un adolescent va utiliser les
réseaux sociaux numériques peut être un
indicateur de souffrance psychique
l'usage donc des réseaux sociaux peut
nous permettre d'être de repérer d'être
un moyen de repérage de cette souffrance
mais ceci doit toujours être
recontactualisé en prenant considération
l'environnement familial scolaire amical
amoureux et bien évidemment la santé
mentale du jeûne
alors un adolescent c'est aussi vous
l'avez entendu un contexte familial un
contexte social scolaire et
psychologique pour reprendre le
psychiatre Winnicott qui disait un bébé
seul ça n'existe pas et bien un
adolescent seul ça n'existe pas il reste
un enfant l'enfant de ses parents et
même si cette période est difficile et
implique une prise d'autonomie
importante et un travail de séparation
pour se construire il est essentiel de
prendre l'adolescent dans sa relation à
son environnement et au monde extérieur
en ce sens la pratique des adolescents
sur les réseaux sociaux ne peut se
penser sans sel des parents et sans un
regard sur l'éducation numérique
qu'apporte les parents à leur enfant
selon une étude de l'Open 53% des
parents ont déjà posté une photo une
vidéo de leurs enfants sur les réseaux
sociaux certains contre rémunération
Tik Tok devient un des réseaux sociaux
numéro numériques pardon le plus utilisé
par les parents notamment les jeunes
parents influenceurs les 18-35 ans et
pour cause la vidéo et le média
privilégié de ses parents et le média
privilégié de Tik Tok toujours selon
cette étude seule 44% des parents
influenceurs ont demandé le consentement
pour publier leurs images à ses enfants
ces chiffres montrent donc que les
enfants sont très tôt présents sur les
réseaux sociaux numériques par le biais
des comptes des parents et qui
n'interroge pas forcément leur propre
pratique numérique
en l'absence d'études scientifiques sur
le sujet mais aussi du peu de recul que
nous avons sur ces pratiques nous
pouvons nous demander ce que ces enfants
d'aujourd'hui dont l'image est exposée
sur les espaces numériques vont devenir
comme adolescent mais aussi comme adulte
de demain sur ces mêmes espaces
numériques
ça nous amène à porter notre attention
du coup sur l'importance d'une éducation
numérique
parce que ce que nous constatons c'est
que les parents d'aujourd'hui sont les
premiers parents à se confronter aux
questions posées par l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux numériques par leurs
enfants
les jeunes parents font aussi partie de
la génération qui sont nés avec les
réseaux sociaux
et pourtant il n'existe pas
d'antériorité à une éducation numérique
contrairement à d'autres aspects de
l'éducation
il faut également noter que
l'utilisation les usages et les réseaux
sociaux chez les adolescents et très
spécifiques et donc différents de
l'usage des adultes
ce qui amène également au constat que
les adultes se retrouvent positionnés
comme figure d'autorité en matière
d'éducation numérique vis-à-vis de leurs
enfants notamment et auront tendance à
vouloir plaquer leur propre perception
et compréhension dans ces usages
qu'elles soient positives ou négative
et pour pallier à ce manque d'éducation
les parents et les adultes d'aujourd'hui
vont également s'éduquer sur les réseaux
sociaux
cette méconnaissance et manque
d'éducation liée aux usages et médias et
du numérique relève de plus en facteurs
d'abord d'un manque d'accès à une des
sources d'information qui soit
l'éducation numérique qui soit fiable
stable sur le temps c'est à dire que les
parents et les adultes ne peuvent pas se
référer à une ou plusieurs instances
référentes et crédibles au sujet
d'éducation numérique
c'est aussi de l'importance de remettre
en question les contenus qu'on publie ou
qu'on consulte
de remettre en question les
comportements qu'on adopte au qu'on
observe sur les réseaux sociaux
numériques c'est
en effet par exemple la publication de
photos d'enfants de leur enfant mineur
ou surgissent à ce moment-là des
problèmes de consentement mais aussi des
questions liées à la permanence de notre
trace numérique de ce qu'on laisse en
ligne pour une durée indéterminée
c'est aussi la difficulté de la
difficulté de savoir
ce dont il faut être attentif ou
attentive sur les réseaux sociaux
l'usage des réseaux sociaux devrait
toujours mobiliser chez nous notre
esprit critique et de la prise de recul
c'est garder à l'esprit des notions
primordiales de confidentialité et de
protection de notre vie intime
c'est constamment en fait se poser la
question pourquoi je m'apprête à faire
ça pourquoi un autre le fait pourquoi un
autre ne le fait pas qu'est-ce que je
gagne qu'est-ce que je qu'est-ce que ça
me coûte
et les adultes n'ont pas toujours la
connaissance de ces notions éducatives
puisqu'il tombe eux-mêmes aussi dans ces
pièges de mes éducation
comme je comme on le disais
ces adultes ne peuvent pas se reporter
ni à une éducation
transmise par une figure de référence
ni à leur propre éducation
de ce fait dans une telle configuration
familiale et éducative comment
pouvons-nous espérer et nous attendre à
ce que les enfants d'aujourd'hui
puissent par eux-mêmes
déployer et mettre en pratique une bonne
éducation numérique
alors ces jeunes les jeunes vont se
replier par eux-mêmes entre eux sur les
réseaux sociaux numériques pour
s'éduquer autrement car comme nous
l'avons dit les adultes les parents ne
représentent pas des figures de
référence et la conjoncture entre
l'écart générationnel et culturel
et le processus d'adolescence en quête
d'identité et de sociabilisation accroît
ce phénomène mais les réseaux sociaux
numériques sont des espaces ou ses
connaissances
d'éducation numérique sont librement
accessibles
de ce fait Tik Tok Instagram YouTube
deviennent des candidats
particulièrement intéressants Tik Tok
devient une source d'information
continue sous le filtre algorithmique
et les réseaux sociaux numériques
deviennent des lieux d'émancipation
identitaire de richesses culturelles et
aussi de risques
et de ce fait laisser les jeunes seuls
sur les réseaux sociaux numériques sans
accompagnement c'est prendre le risque
que certaines influences potentiellement
néfastes puissent surgir là où
l'adolescent l'adolescente n'a pas
toujours la maturité suffisante pour
traiter et faire preuve d'esprit
critique concernant ces dites influences
l'enjeu de l'éducation numérique c'est
d'encourager l'autonomie la
responsabilisation et la sécurité des
usages des outils numériques
pour terminer
sur ce volet
c'est l'importance de valoriser les
compétences parentales et adultes certes
la jeunesse a toujours un coup d'avance
en matière d'innovation de découverte de
curiosité de technologie mais le monde
adulte possède également d'autres
compétences essentielles
dont les jeunes ont besoin l'expérience
le recul la nostalgie du passé
les compétences de résolution de
conflits
l'accompagnement des usages numériques
chez les jeunes nécessitent que les
adultes les parents puissent aller à
leur endroit et aussi leur montrer
d'autres formes façons contemporaine
d'utiliser ces outils numériques
tout n'est pas binaire il y a toujours
des nuances en tout ça
alors vous l'aurez entendu malgré la
spécificité de Tik Tok de par son
algorithme et ses fonctionnalités Tik
Tok dans le contexte de l'adolescence
n'est ni plus ni moins un réseau social
numérique pris dans une pratique
numérique multiple il ne s'agit donc pas
de se centrer uniquement sur l'objet
numérique quel est le réseau social
TikTok mais de prendre en considération
plus largement l'environnement familial
éducatif social et politique il s'agit
donc de déployer une vision multifocale
des usages numériques en ce sens
l'éducation numérique doit devenir une
priorité nationale autant auprès des
parents que des enfants en déployant les
moyens nécessaires pour intervenir
auprès de ses diverses populations au
plus proche de leur quotidien mais
attention cette éducation numérique ne
doit pas se résumer à la prévention des
risques encourus sur les réseaux sociaux
elle doit se bancer en deçà dans un
accompagnement et un soutien à la
parentalité en valorisant les
compétences parentales mais aussi les
compétences des adultes ultes mais aussi
à l'attention des enfants dès le plus
jeune âge pour développer leur capacité
d'esprit critique à l'usage du numérique
je vous remercie
merci mesdames si Monsieur Merci
beaucoup
pour cette exposé
je crois qu'on a mis on a bien fait de
vous inviter en complément et en nuance
des questions
quantitatives et statistiques sont
fondamentales mais sur les spécialités
merci infiniment pour vous vos
réflexions je passe tout de suite la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur pour ces
questions et les collègues qui veulent
intervenir également j'ai noté madame
boulet Speroni madame Boyer même moins
de saillie voilà vous me faites un petit
signe
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à tous les trois pour cette
exposés préliminaire et les
diapositives et la compagnie qui en
facilitent la convention et
d'interprétation
j'ai bien je voudrais vous poser un
certain nombre de questions peu de
questions parce que visiblement pas mal
de nos
collègues ils me l'ont dit avant la
réunion souhaite poser des questions
donc je voudrais pas utiliser tout le
temps que nous avons et leur temps de
parole et leurs questions
mais au moins je voudrais vous poser
deux ou trois questions
comme vous l'avez notamment synthétisé
dans votre conclusion
l'une des remarques principales que vous
nous faites c'est que kick-up s'inscrit
dans une pratique numérique multiple
et consacré à l'ensemble des réseaux
sociaux ou à plusieurs réseaux sociaux
pour chaque enfant et adolescents
puisque on parle de ce matin plutôt des
enfants des adolescents en ce qui nous
concerne nous nous faisons une
commission d'enquête sur Tik Tok donc
tout en comprenant cette pratique
numérique multiple nous cherchons à
comprendre les spécificités que peut
avoir Tik Tok par rapport aux autres
réseaux sociaux et la première de ces
spécificités qui nous est très souvent
mis en avant pas par des psychologues
essentiellement mais notamment quand
mais aussi par des techniciens de
l'informatique et des réseaux sociaux
c'est c'est la dictativité de son
algorithme
[Musique]
on constate que de nombreux adolescents
plusieurs occasions linguistiques ont
montré
alterne entre les phases de
désinstallation de Tik Tok parce qu'ils
Simpsons parce qu'ils deviennent addict
justement
et au détriment de leurs devoirs de leur
famille de leurs amis etc et puis il le
réinstalle et puis le désinstalle à
nouveau on est un petit peu dans le
syndrome du fumeur qui s'arrête qui ne
peut pas s'empêcher qui reprend etc
quand je dis quand je compare aux
fumeurs c'est bien entendu parce qu'on
nous sommes en train de parler
d'addiction
et par conséquent ce problème
semble se poser beaucoup plus sur Tik
Tok que sur les autres réseaux sociaux
pour une raison que les techniciens que
les ingénieurs
nous disent être celle
de l'hyperaddictivité de l'algorithme de
Tik Tok et notamment le fait qu'il soit
addictif by design
par par construction
et donc ce n'est pas seulement une
question d'usage mais c'est aussi une
question de de construction de de
l'application donc la première question
c'est est-ce que vous pensez de ce point
de vue là qu'il y a une spécificité de
Tik Tok et qu'il y a une véritable
différence d'addictivité de par avec les
autres réseaux sociaux
pour la question
peut-être d'abord rebondir sur ce que
signifie
le principe d'addiction de
comportemental
nous pouvons définir l'addiction
comportementale sur trois dimensions il
y a l'intensité la fréquence et la durée
et les trois dimensions doivent être
sous une espèce de tyrannie et en et
ensemble donc cela veut dire que
analyser un comportement uniquement sur
l'un des trois l'une de ces trois
dimensions uniquement n'est insuffisante
pour déterminer s'il y a présence ou non
une addiction comportementale donc
l'exemple le plus simple c'est quand on
est sur une série Netflix je dis
n'importe quoi et qu'on regarde
d'affilée en une semaine plusieurs
heures d'affilée est-ce que cette
personne est addict non parce que
on est que sur une seule dimension qui
ne persiste pas dans la durée
intensité
généralement la préoccupation est
focalisée sur la fréquence donc le
nombre de d'heures de minutes de
l'utilisation d'un objet mais voilà
gardons en tête cette redimension de ce
fait dans l'addiction comportementale le
la dimension la plus importante à
retenir c'est l'intensité l'intensité ce
que cela veut dire c'est à quel point
est-ce que cette usage de l'objet va
être va dominé les autres aspects de la
vie de de la personne qui utilise cet
objet
donc cela passe par les besoins vitaux
mais ça la passe pas aussi par les
besoins qu'on dira peut-être secondaire
mais en tout cas les besoins donc
scolaires professionnels les besoins
familiaux les besoins sociaux les
besoins de
culturels divertissement des loisirs etc
et c'est là où
comment
l'attention l'attention doit être portée
de manière le plus importantes à quel
point est-ce que cet usage de l'objet et
je précise bien objet pour englober
toutes formes de comportement prend le
dessus
sur la vie d'un individu
sur la spécifique donc maintenant quand
on a défini l'addiction comportementale
je ne peux pas vraiment parler en termes
l'algorithme peut-être que je peux te
laisserai je te laisserai la parole
Thomas mais pour parler
d'activité
d'une application cela s'entendrait que
tout usage de cet objet là provoquerait
des processus addicts addictifs
ceux qui n'est pas le cas en tout cas
puisque nous avons très bien des données
des expériences que quand on utilise un
objet qui a un caractère édogène nous ne
devons pas forcément
sous l'emprise d'addiction
de la même manière je pense que on peut
penser les choses comme la personne qui
se retrouve sous l'emprise une addiction
quelconque
pense trouver son compte là-dedans donc
là je parle pas que de l'usage des
réseaux sociaux je parle de toute forme
de compote sous forme de comportement
[Musique]
le comportement en soi n'a pas tant de
caractères c'est combien combien est-ce
que la personne qui qui
se qui pratiquent en fait qu'est-ce
qu'il y trouve là-dedans
je pense à l'exemple de l'addiction au
sexe par exemple ou dans l'addiction au
sexe le sexe en soi n'est pas
addictogène pour autant il existe des
cas d'addictions aux ex est-ce que cela
pourrait faire du coup au parallèle que
le sexe
serait
un degré d'activité
je ne pense pas
parler je termine parler d'activité
par rapport à un objet c'est vouloir le
rapprocher aux acteurs d'addictions avec
des substances sous le principe qu'on
consomme dans ce cas de figure des
réseaux sociaux que
lorsqu'on ingère alors des
réseaux sociaux on va commencer à plus
tolérer les réseaux sociaux et en
demander plus ce que je ne pense pas
qu'on observe
merci
juste ajouter par rapport aux propos de
2000 ans que
il n'y a pas de consensus
scientifique sur le terme d'addiction
que ce soit sur les jeux vidéo ou sur
les réseaux sociaux numériques il y a eu
quand même une grosse polémique sur
le DSM c'est M5 c'est à dire le manuel
de psychiatrie où il a été proposé le
trouble le désordeur de Game des order
le trouble des jeux vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux alors d'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de de troubles dit addictifs
aux réseaux sociaux donc voilà il y a
quand même quelque chose aussi à pointer
au niveau scientifique et psychiatrique
où finalement et voilà il y a pas de
consensus sur cette notion d'addiction
par contre ce que je trouve intéressant
dans votre question c'est que quand on
lit la technique à un terme d'addiction
non à terme de psychiatrie c'est que ça
vient quand même repérer un comportement
et ce comportement il me semble que
plutôt que parler d'addiction on
pourrait parler d'abrutissement des
images du flux vidéo qui en effet fait
qu'à un moment donné parce que on est
capté par l'écran et par ce flux vidéo
qui nous abrutit l'oeil et bien on
pourrait
ne plus voir ce qui nous entoure c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment comme ça focus
sur l'écran et donc plus qu'addiction il
me semble qu'il est plus juste de parler
d'abrutissement des images et de ce flux
vidéo plutôt que de psychiatriser
l'usage d'un réseau social
merci beaucoup je vais poursuivre je
m'apprêtais avant votre dernière phrase
à vous citer
[Musique]
quelques phrases d'un auteur qui a
écrit récemment un livre il y a
plusieurs livres assez grand public
assez comment dire beaucoup de succès
qui sur l'usage des réseaux sociaux
vous le connaissez certainement puisque
son titre lui-même est déjà addictif si
je peux dire c'est le crétinisme la
fabrique du créateur digital
et qui
[Musique]
pour le moins qu'on puisse dire n'a pas
les mêmes
scrupules que que vous-même pour pour
dire un certain nombre de choses et
justement
lui
ne parle pas tellement d'addiction mais
d'aboutissement de je vous cite une ou
deux freins le message de la littérature
scientifique alors lui le message est
littéraire scientifique disponible vous
nous avez dit en commençant il y a
pratiquement pas d'études pas d'études
françaises et pas d'études sur Tik Tok
sur Tik Tok notamment ça se comprend
parce que c'est beaucoup plus plus
récent etc et notamment en France
bon lui apparemment l'air de dire mais
je pense qu'il parle de l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux y compris ceux qui sont
là depuis 10 ou 15 ans le message de la
littérature scientifique disponible est
clair cohérent et claire quand il rend
et
indiscutable plus les élèves lycées un
collégiens et étudiants consacre de
temps à leur joujoux numérique et plus
leur niveau scolaire baisse jamais sans
doute dans l'histoire de l'humanité une
telle expérience de décérébration
n'avait été conduite à aussi grande
échelle 30 à 60 minutes d'exposition aux
réseaux sociaux à la télévision aux jeux
vidéo suffisent à affecter le
développement intellectuel et les
résultats scolaires de l'enfant donc on
rentre dans ce que vous décrivez comme
l'abrutissement est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est que cette phrase que je
pourrais j'aurais pu en prendre beaucoup
d'eau dans ce livre ou dans le livre un
succès également de Patino et d'autres
auteurs est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
exagèrent vous avez l'air beaucoup plus
relativis
ant que que
monsieur le rapporteur je vous souhaite
référence à un ouvrage d'art monsieur
qui avait écrit précédemment un autre
ouvrage qui s'appelait TV lobotomi
sans vouloir présager ou préjugé de du
parti pris de cet auteur en ce qui
concerne la manière dont les outils
numériques sont utilisés par les enfants
de toute façon comme la très bien dit
angélique
c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui étudié
scruté mais pas de la manière la plus
on va dire scientifique possible
aujourd'hui c'est les effets qui ont été
évoqués par Monsieur desmurgés dans son
dans son ouvrage ont été par la suite
démenties par un certain nombre de
scientifiques au regard de son analyse
biaisée et notamment l'oubli
qu'une preuve scientifique n'est pas un
effet corrélation mais bien un effet la
démonstration d'un effet de causalité
ce qui ce que Grégoire border ça a dû
évidemment
évoqué avec vous
aujourd'hui bien sûr je vais juste pour
conclure et je vais laisser la parole à
Angélique et Milan rappeler le rapport
du HCSP qui précise bien qu'aujourd'hui
notamment dans la manière dont on
définit la notion d'écran et de tout ce
qui pourrait y avoir comme impact
négatif cette notion d'écran
d'étudier dans la recherche scientifique
au niveau mondial que ce manque depuis
2018 contrairement à ce qu'on a ce qu'on
entend et la plupart des études qui sont
évoquées par Monsieur desmurger dans son
ouvrage repose sur la télévision la
télévision ou là on a une littérature
scientifique beaucoup plus fournie
depuis très nombreuses années ça ne veut
pas dire que ce qu'il évoque n'a pas de
sens ça veut juste dire qu'aujourd'hui
et je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit
angélique selon
les démonstrations et je pense qu'il est
une fois encore Grégoire ça a dû vous le
confirmer
selon les principes de ce qu'est une
recherche scientifique les effets
uniquement corrélatoires ne peuvent être
qu'une source d'inspiration à pousser
plus amplement des recherches et non pas
une certitude et une véracité en termes
de conclusion scientifique
encore une ou deux questions et
avant de passer la parole à mes
collègues ah pardon
je voulais préciser quelque chose sur
votre question monsieur le rapporteur je
voulais préciser de l'importance de ne
pas confondre ce qu'on appelle un effet
de corrélation et un effet de causalité
et ce que l'exemple que vous utilisez
monsieur le rapporteur
par l'auteur de La Fabrique du critère
digital du créateur digital virgule
c'est que il semble faire une
observation
qui lui permettrait à ce moment là
d'emblée de d'émettre un effet de
causalité or il est impossible où ce
serait plutôt erroné de faire un de
procéder à un effet de causalité en
absence de l'État études
c'est-à-dire d'une étude qui font qui
regroupe les études faites sur un sujet
ça me fait penser à
une donnée que de tout à l'heure d'un
des graphique je vous ai montré qu'il
n'apparaissait pas d'une étude que je
vous ai montré qui n'apparaissait pas
c'était de noter par exemple que dans
les populations plus pauvres aux
États-Unis notamment des populations
noires et panique l'utilisation de Tik
Tok est Instagram et beaucoup plus
importantes elle est comme elle s'élève
de 10 à 15% plus de plus
ce qui est aussi important à noter c'est
que les populations qui ont qui sont
plus pauvres vont utiliser plus de
réseaux sociaux numériques de manière
globale
[Musique]
là si on devait faire un effet de
causalité ce serait une erreur
scientifique et il est extrêmement
important à ce moment-là de se poser la
question de pourquoi c'est pas plutôt
quelles sont les spécificités de
l'environnement de ces populations là
qui vont les pousser ou en tout cas
vouloir utiliser plus souvent certains
réseaux sociaux numériques notamment des
réseaux sociaux numériques short form
donc Instagram Tic-Toc snapchat et
YouTube short
que on pourrait très bien aussi penser
que c'est lié à des facteurs
environnementaux sociaux culturels
qui nourrissent ces habitudes
comportementales merci
merci bien alors
de l'effet pharmacon j'ai fait
positif et négatif à la fois
d'une application
et vous avez évoqué
la nécessité de limiter les effets
négatifs et notamment et vous avez
conclu par cela sur l'importance de
l'éducation annuelle d'éducation à la
fois parentale et des enfants
mais vous ne avez pas donné de piste
est-ce que vous en avez sur les
recommandations que que je ne sais pas
si l'Open fait des recommandations à ce
sujet Quel serait vos pistes sur
ces recommandations pour les parents et
pour les enfants qui permettent de
lutter contre tous les effets négatifs
de ce pharmacon
justement je pense que monsieur le
rapporteur une partie de la réponse et
dans votre question et comme cela a été
dit précédemment par par Milan et
Angélique je pense que aujourd'hui quand
on y réfléchit bien dans tout ce qui est
entrepris depuis plusieurs décennies en
termes de politique publique en la
matière que ce soit dans l'éducation
nationale ou en dehors on ne raisonne
uniquement qu'au travers de l'évitement
du risque
c'est à dire qu'on est au coeur d'une
énorme contradiction sociétale et
éducative
comme le montre nos études désormais le
premier smartphone des enfants arrive
entre leurs mains en fin de CM1 quel que
soit le milieu social
comme j'aime à le dire parfois pour un
petit peu rassurer les parents et amener
un peu quelques sourires sur leurs
lèvres lors de nos échanges avec eux sur
le terrain je n'ai jamais vu d'enfants
de 5 ans
attaqué un camion Samsung ou Apple et
donc quelque part il y a une
responsabilité me semble-t-il
sociétale à réfléchir et à penser le
pourquoi de l'équipement et quand on
questionne les parents dans nos études
sur ces sur ce sujet précis les réponses
sont toujours très unanimes il s'agit
pour eux d'outils ayant pour vocation à
les rassurer
on est dans une logique souvent de
réassurance personnelle les parents nous
répondent j’équipe mon enfant parce que
je souhaite qu'il soit que je puisse je
souhaite pouvoir le joindre 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 une enquête récente
publiée où j'étais interviewée dans
Libération montrer que tout cela avait
pour incidence globalement cette
angoisse parentale à un resserrement du
champ d'investigation des enfants dans
un périmètre de quelques centaines de
mètres autour du domicile alors qu'au
préalable il était plusieurs kilomètres
y compris cette réassurance pousse même
certains parents à des comportements
radicaux
je pense ici aux quatre familles sur 10
en France qui installent un logiciel
espion sur le téléphone de leurs enfants
une fois après les en avoir équipés je
pense à ces témoignages que j'ai
recueilli lors de groupes de paroles
avec des membres de l'éducation
nationale ou certains enseignants me
rapportaient que des parents et qui peut
parfois dès la fin de la maternelle
leurs enfants de montre connectée pour
pouvoir bien sûr les géolocaliser mais
aussi pour pouvoir écouter ce que dit
l'enseignant
à distance
vous voyez ici à travers ces quelques
exemples que je vous livre qu'on est au
cœur me semble-t-il d'une énorme
contradiction sociétale parentale et
éducative et que parmi les pistes que
nous préconisons c'est pour ça que nous
on se définit clairement comme étant une
association à la fois de protection de
l'enfance mais de soutient la
parentalité et que pour parvenir à cet
objectif on a décidé de nous adresser
aux adultes parents et professionnels et
non pas aux enfants parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand on y regarde de près une fois
encore on équipe les enfants de plus en
plus tôt jamais il n'y a
d'accompagnement éducatifs qu'il aurait
proposé à bien utiliser les outils on ne
fait que leur demander leur montrer ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire
et ça quand même quelque part au niveau
éducatif me semble-t-il c'est assez
questionnant et ça vient évidemment
on va dire amplifier
parfois les les difficultés qui passent
familiales qui passent par beaucoup de
conflits quand il s'agit dans les
familles de parler d'utilisation du
smartphone ou des réseaux sociaux
puisque on est uniquement dans une
logique d'évitement des risques un peu
comme si être parents en 2023 et très
adulte quand il s'agit d'accompagner un
enfant un adolescent dans l'espace
numérique consistait à être dans un film
Marvel endosser son costume de
super-héros tous les matins et à se dire
aujourd'hui n'arrivera rien à mon enfant
il me semble que l'éducation ne peut pas
être que cela et aujourd'hui
l'autonomisation des enfants est souvent
sacrifiée à l'aune de l'évitement unique
des risques des enfants dans les espaces
numériques et je conclurai là dessus on
peut pas dire que ce soit un vrai succès
non plus de ce côté là en termes
d'évitement des risques puisque selon
les dires même des structures qui sont
en charge de la prévention et de la
sensibilisation notamment dans les
établissements scolaires sur ces
questions là il y a jamais eu autant de
cyber-harcèlement il y a jamais autant
de jeunes qui sont victimes de si et de
ça et donc je pense aussi que là on a un
gros travail de réflexion à faire et à
mener tous ensemble conjointement pour
redéfinir complètement ce que c'est une
éducation au numérique en 2023
merci oui allez-y
fais juste revenir sur une toute petite
anecdote que j'ai eu lors d'une étude
qui a été menée avec le ministère de la
Justice sur l'impact des images trash à
l'adolescence sans qui a été un rapport
sorti en 2017 avec Sophie JL et qui en
interviewant un jeune adolescent en
établissement pénitencier pour mineur
quand on lui a fait le retour de la de
la de l'étude on lui a demandé on a
demandé à tous nos jeunes qu'est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut mettre en place
pour éviter les risques sur les réseaux
sociaux et Internet et ce jeune nous a
répondu et il a pas été le seul mais
écoutez madame c'est pas en intervenant
dans les collèges avec un gendarme et un
juriste etc ça c'est cool ça nous fait
perdre 2 heures de temps mais c'est
auprès de nos parents qu'il faut
intervenir
voilà juste
si je vois que mes collections donc je
pose juste je suis une dernière question
bien que
malgré le fait que j'en avais pas mal
d'autres
je continue sur le pharmacon en matière
d'image de soi d'image corporelle
notamment vous avez dit tout à l'heure
le côté positif c'est de trouver les
moyens de construire son identité
notamment à travers les usages du corps
je ne reviens pas sur ce que vous avez
dit le côté négatif c'est évidemment
en miroir les possibilités
notamment vous l'avez cité de
dysmorphophobie et d'un certain nombre
de d'autres syndromes
négatif
je veux de ce point de vue là il semble
que ces effets négatifs et notamment en
matière de dysmorphophobie ou de
l'alimentation sont plus importants sur
les adolescentes de est-ce que vous avez
vous avez une opinion là-dessus
et une question qui l'a poursuit en
février 2022 Tik Tok a dit avoir mis à
jour ses règles communautaires pour
supprimer les contenus encourageants des
troubles de l'alimentation de
l'alimentation ce qui est en soi une
reconnaissance du fait que l'application
suicide des trou de l'alimentation
est-ce que vous avez constaté un
changement depuis cette date puisque ça
fait déjà un peu plus d'un an
cliniquement je moi je n'ai pas
d'éléments cliniques auprès de des
consultations que ce soit des collègues
en tout cas là où j'interviens en
pédopsychiatrie à villevrard il y a pas
de de
d'éléments qui viendrait collaborer ce
que vous venez de dire je voilà et
notamment il n'y a pas plus de troupes
du comportement alimentaire
qui viennent consulter en psychiatrie
liées aux réseaux sociaux ça ça avait
déjà été le cas il me semble avec les
les blogs de Skyrock qui est qui avait
été pointé du doigt parce que c'était
des espaces d'expression pour les proana
il y a toujours des communautés proana
sur les réseaux sociaux ça a toujours
été ça a été c'était aussi le cas sur
Facebook à l'époque en 2014 donc du coup
c'est à dire que ce sont des communautés
qui vont essayer de trouver des lieux
d'expression qui vont trouver des
interlocuteurs qui se posent des
questions et c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure là le risque c'est une
radicalisation de la pensée chez les
jeunes parce qu'ils vont être enfermés
dans une communauté qui ne pense que la
même chose mais bien sûr que le trouble
du comp fortement alimentaire n'est pas
à impliquer par l'usage des réseaux
sociaux il va être
sous-jacent c'est à dire qu'il y a un
enjeu familial sous-jacent un enjeu
interne déjà préexistant et qui va se
déployer sur la sphère des réseaux
sociaux mais voilà c'est encore une fois
c'est c'est une façon un peu de
psychiatriser l'usage des réseaux
sociaux qui est très questionnante
on est tous au fait ça part avec les
tout-petits enfants qui à qui on donne
les téléphones portables des 18 mois ou
un an où là ça en effet ça crée des
troubles à caractère autistique et ça on
le voit très bien dans nos pratiques
mais sinon il faut vraiment faire
attention à ces passages là c'est assez
raccourci là
les TCA les troubles alimentaires
l'impact des images de soi viennent
juste voilà
être mis en exergue par les réseaux
sociaux ou l'adolescent va trouver des
réponses à son mal-être voilà
si vous pouvez le comment dire peut-être
qu'à l'occasion des questions qui seront
posées vous aurez l'occasion de préciser
les choses madame boulet
madame Boyer on va essayer de prendre
plusieurs questions et
grouper les réponses merci monsieur le
président le plus rapidement possible
vous avez dit d'abord que il y avait pas
d'étude scient
ifiques sur les
effets est-ce qu'il y a des études qui
ont été faites dans d'autres pays
d'Europe ou ailleurs dans le monde et
spécifiquement sur Tik Tok de manière
générale sur les réseaux ou est-ce que
de manière générale sur les réseaux ce
ne serait pas éclairant sur ce qui nous
préoccupe dans cette commission
c'est-à-dire les effets de Tik Tok
deuxièmement matière de comportement
addictif qui est l'une des choses bien
évidemment qui nous préoccupent au sein
de cette commission d'enquête vous avez
dit dans les études que YouTube était de
loin le réseau le plus investi
et que 64% des jeunes utilisaient 38% ne
pourraient s'en passer c'est une phrase
qui selon moi est lourde de sens
qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire s'ils
étaient amenés à s'en passer qu'est-ce
que ça implique et lorsque vous avez dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de troubles addictif
lié au réseau en tant que tel est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas parler aussi de
troubles addictifs liés au dispositif
lui-même c'est-à-dire un outil c'est à
dire au téléphone portable et dans ces
cas-là nous sommes peut-être un certain
nombre d'être atteint et enfin
troisièmement oui c'est ça alors par
rapport à là en plus vous avez dit oui
par rapport à la socialisation qui est
le propre et l'apanage de enfin qui est
très important et essentiel pour
l'adolescent
quand vous parlez de sentiment
d'appartenance ça veut dire que est-ce
que c'est une vraie ou une fausse
appartenance et surtout la panache de ce
que souhaite l'adolescence et surtout de
s'extraire de la sphère familiale et
donc dans le dispositif qu'on a tous mis
en place depuis très longtemps du
contrôle parental ça veut dire qu'il y
aura une contradiction terrible puisque
le contrôle parental est totalement en
fait
va à l'encontre totalement de ce que
l'adolescence souhaite en s'extrayant de
la sphère familiale et justement du
contrôle parental en tant parent et du
camp etc voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
je me permets juste de faire une petite
remarque rapide pour répondre à un
certain nombre d'interrogations que vous
avez eu
savoir que cette semaine au Sénat il y a
eu deux textes un sur les influenceurs
numériques mardi et hier soir un sur le
la proposition de loi visant au respect
du droit à l'image des enfants dans
laquelle je vous avais auditionné
et donc effectivement on va vers un
meilleur respect de la vie privée des
enfants ça c'est-à-dire sur le fait que
on essaye de siffler la fin de la partie
de l'insouciance numérique des parents
qui postent des milliers de photos de
leurs enfants sur des réseaux sociaux
ouverts
sans oublier et parfois effectivement en
utilisant ce qu'on appelle des pranks on
en avait discuté longuement
ceci étant la semaine prochaine on aura
un autre texte sur la majorité numérique
il y a les travaux de Tik Tok il y a la
proposition de loi qui avait fait notre
collègue madame Morin de saillie sur le
la prévention d'exposition excessive des
enfants aux écrans bref j'en oublie
sûrement tout le monde réfléchit en ce
moment dans un ordre dispersé ce que je
trouve dommage est-ce que ce que nous
avons tous déploré hier auprès du
ministre en disant que c'était vraiment
dommage qu'on travaille pas tous
ensemble sur un texte qui qui aurait
plusieurs vertus d'abord une
coordination et ensuite de sur une vertu
pédagogique auprès des parents parce que
je suis sûr que s'il Parlement s'emparer
d'un texte cohérent et large à ce moment
là ça aurait été répercussions sur
l'information des parents ma question
est la suivante tout à l'heure monsieur
le rapporteur vous a demandé quels
étaient vos préconisations
concrètes
et je vais rebondir sur cette question
parce que c'est la est-ce que vous
pensez que réactualiser le carnet de
santé qui ne l'a pas été fait depuis
2018 et notamment en créant une page
enfin en créant des recommandations à la
fois sur l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux le temps d'exposition etc ce
qu'avait préconisé notre collègue mais
aussi en rajoutant un pavé ou un
chapitre sur la protection de la vie
privée en disant que les parents sont
responsables de ce qu'ils mettent sur
leurs enfants première chose
deuxièmement que pensez-vous d'un
programme d'un programme de santé
publique
je me dis bien d'un programme scolaire
de santé publique qui permettrait
effectivement de parler des bonnes
pratiques mais aussi des dangers du
numérique de l'alimentation du sommeil
de du harcèlement de
les choses sont variées et enfin
l'ouverture d'un livre dans le code de
la santé publique sur l'usage du
numérique parce que effectivement si on
peut peut-être pas parler de comme vous
le disiez madame de d'addiction parler
d'abrutissement de troubles de la
concentration
d'un certain nombre de choses et
effectivement de l'usage addictif du
téléphone qui ne concerne pas que les
enfants d'ailleurs et qui concerne
maintenant aujourd'hui tout le monde
puisqu'on le touche je ne sais pas
combien de fois par jour on l'a avec
nous c'est un objet on dort avec
c'est devenu quelque chose de qui fait
partie intégrante de notre vie et même
presque un prolongement de notre corps
qu'est-ce que ça signifie aujourd'hui et
effectivement qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour pour nos enfants donc c'est ces
trois questions là quels sont vos
recommandations concrètes pour
justement pour protéger les plus jeunes
si vous pouviez nous faire une répondre
à ces deux questions pour qu'on puisse
voir clair et après comme ça on prend le
temps c'est celle-ci c'est un peu lié
balise allez-y je pense que c'est lié au
propos de ma collègue Valérie Boyer qui
a beaucoup parlé d'éducation d'éducation
nationale premièrement je voulais savoir
si vos études s'appuient sur des
échanges aussi que vous avez pu voir
avec d'autres cordes experts et
spécialistes je pense bien sûr à des
orthophonistes des pédiatres des
psychiatres vous avez évoqué par des
pardonnez-moi de vous contredire ou
alors les mal compris qu'il y a eu peu
d'études réalisées sur les écrans hormis
la télévision je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous je pense que
l'excellent psychanalyse Serge Tisseron
a depuis longtemps théorisé
l'approche des écrans à quel moment il
fallait introduire d'ailleurs les écrans
dans la vie des des enfants on a eu
l'occasion de l'auditionner à plusieurs
reprises au Sénat et je crois que
c'était le premier en réalité à
s'occuper de ces questions dès
l'avènement du numérique à mesurer à
quel point il y aurait des conséquences
en matière d'apprentissage des
conséquences sur les comportements etc
donc je pense que ces travaux sont
vraiment aujourd'hui une référence donc
avait vu des contacts justement pour
alimenter
votre propre action avec avec Serge
Tisseron ou d'autres
experts du du secteur ça c'est ma
première question vous avez beaucoup
concentré l'éducation sur la question
des parents je partage complètement les
parents doivent prendre leur
responsabilités sont les premiers à
devoir s'occuper de ces sujets malgré
tout l'éducation nationale doit jouer un
rôle complémentaire évident je rappelle
que le Sénat fait inscrire en 2011 dans
le code de l'éducation l'obligation de
la sensibilisation des enfants au risque
et aux potentialité de l'Internet il
faut vérifier comment ça se met en
application aller vérifier peut-être
aussi avez-vous des contacts avec les
autorités de l'éducation nationale sur
l'application de la loi de 2013
dans la loi plus récente de Jean-Michel
Blancarde école de la confiance qui
introduit des éléments que le Sénat Yami
sur justement la formation des
formateurs sur ces sujets des écrans
apprendre à s'en servir à prendre à s'en
passer nous avons pas toujours
possibilité malheureusement d'avoir
beaucoup de renseignements sur le sujet
mais sur l'interroge chaque année
la cuisson de la culture là-dessus
combien d'argent et consacré de manière
effective combien d'heures sont
consacrées quel thème sont abordés quels
sont les évaluations faites auprès des
enfants tout ça est un travail de fond
monsieur le rapporteur qui souhaite
avoir des des des comment dirais-je des
propositions concrètes il y a des choses
à évaluer déjà donc vous qui vous
occupez de ça de manière extrêmement
militante avez-vous des indicateurs à
partager avec nous je vous remercie
c'est comme on est ce que si c'est lié
allons-y oui
merci monsieur le Président
plusieurs remarques les premières la
première c'est que j'imagine bien que
pour le président le rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquête il y aura quelque
chose d'un peu frustrant dans cette
audition parce que non mais il y a pas
ils nous intervenants bien expliqué il y
a pas on isole pas TikTok de l'ensemble
des comportements de consommation et de
des réseaux sociaux par les enfants et
les adolescents
et de ce point de vue là ça croise et ça
fait référence à des réflexions que nous
avons déjà dans d'autres commissions
dans d'autres cercles depuis longtemps
sur la question des enfants et des
réseaux sociaux alors j'aurai une
question technique et quelques quelques
remarques je commence par la question
technique je crois que c'est vous madame
ou tout à l'heure qui avait dit que sur
Tik Tok les contes des enfants de moins
de 15 ans sont considérés a priori comme
des comptes privés comment il est alors
ma question certains vont comprendre
pourquoi je la pose comment ils
identifient que ce sont des enfants de
moins de 15 ans voilà
donc ça c'est une question technique
après je préfère plusieurs remarques
peut-être pour aider à nos réflexions
d'abord
Catherine c'était il y a un instant
Serge Tisseron on pourrait citer aussi
Michel Serres la petite poussette etc
pour dire quand même à quel point nous
avons été dans un premier temps très
complaisant à l'égard de ces affaires de
Digital d'Internet et d'accès des
enfants à Internet il fallait surtout
pas avoir l'air d'être déconnecté des
nouvelles générations et on a été des
intellectuels ont été très complaisants
voilà j'ai pas d'autres mots et
insuffisamment à mon avis vigilant et
prudent sur ces questions sur les
questions d'éducation d'abord on parle
on parle pas de zéro il y a eu il existe
des dispositifs je pense à un en
particulier que les promeneurs du net
qui est un dispositif qui a été mis en
place par les cas par la CNAV sur ses
fonds sociaux sur les fonds de soutien
la parentalité pardon qui fonctionne pas
si mal mais je me pose quand même la
question à un moment donné que son
prenne ça parle bien de l'éducation
nationale compr ennent ça par le biais
des parents de l'éducation des parents
est-ce que l'éducation peut lutter
contre la puissance
de l'image en fait est-ce que ça c'est
la première question et je n'en suis pas
sûr voilà je n'en suis pas sûr voir même
je perplexe pour tout vous dire et avec
derrière une deuxième remarque c'est que
la limite je trouve des questions
d'éducation
c'est que
c'est comment parler l'éducation on
accroît ou non les inégalités sociales
et culturelles sur ces usages là
je vais partir d'un exemple d'une
constatation simple dans les CSP+ il y a
pas un enfant
diplômés il y a pas un jeune enfant de
moins de 3 ans qui touche un téléphone
portable ou un écran ce n'est même
comment vous dire à la limite intégriste
voilà
comment
non mais moi aussi je vois mais à la
limite il faut surtout faut retourner le
téléphone voilà mais
voilà nous sommes des CSP+ et nous
voyons ça et j'observe quand je vais
dans un endroit beaucoup plus populaire
dans des restaurants qui a des quantités
d'enfants à qui on donne le téléphone au
supermarché à qui on donne le téléphone
pour que les parents et la paix et la
question de l'éducation elle sort quand
même aux conditions réelles de vie des
gens 25% de famille monoparentales des
mers épuisées je veux bien qu'on leur
dise qu'il faut pas donner le téléphone
aux enfants c'est très compliqué c'est
plus compliqué c'est plus compliqué pour
elle que pour d'autres et comment on
fait pour que en misant tout sur
l'éducation en fait on accroisse pas les
inégalités voilà ça c'est et qu'il a
fait l'éducation donc à quel moment il
faut passer dans le coercitif
ou le prohibitif voilà ce sujet est posé
on est sur la table et enfin je suis
parfait dans l'accord avec vous sur
corrélation et causalité
il y a des corrélations qui méritent
quand même d'être qui mérite d'être
exploré l'augmentation du taux
d'augmentation du taux de suicide chez
les adolescents qui est différencié de
celui des garçons
et corréler avec l'usage d'Instagram
dans les pays et pourquoi Instagram
c'est pas par hasard c'est parce que
c'est des filtres et l'image voilà
c'est une pour le moment c'est une
corrélation mais c'est ce qui est encore
elle d'autres la demande croissante des
mêmes jeunes filles de recours à la
chirurgie esthétique d'autres
corrélations et liées voilà je dis ça
parce que à un moment donné avec des
corrélations on peut quand même arriver
à avoir des préoccupations sur des
effets des usages
pour éviter la frustration d'en parler
madame Rossignol je propose que Madame
Mercier pose sa question et après nous
n'y reviendrons que si monsieur le
rapporteur a vraiment une question à la
fin comme ça ça vous donne un petit un
bon 10 minutes 10 12 minutes pour
merci de vous interrogations juste une
précision entre une différence entre
addiction et dépendance l'addiction vous
avez bien expliqué intensité du
référence la dépendance ça se qualifie
un peu différemment circulaire quand on
est dépendant on va augmenter la dose si
je puis dire et surtout ça va se
diagnostiquer quand on arrête l'objet
donc c'est un peu la question de ma
collègue quand on va arrêter
l'exposition à Tik Tok par exemple quel
va être le symptôme c'est ça la
différence entre addiction et dépendance
donc est-ce qu'il y a une addiction ou
une dépendance au réseau
nous écoutons
débrouillez-vous avec tout ça
on vous écoute
madame
allez-y
alors je vais rebondir en essayant de
regrouper
certaines questions notamment sur la
question des préconisations concrètes
qui me semblent se relier aux questions
autour de l'éducation nationale ou de du
code de l'éducation nationale
en effet là sur ces questions là il y a
au niveau très concret il y a en effet
quelque chose à mettre en place au
niveau des programmes scolaires ça c'est
évident pour
pourquoi mon mon propos s'appuie sur
des la recherche que j'ai menée avec
Sophie gel qui est sociologue qui a
montré qu'au niveau des de la formation
des professeurs des écoles et des
professeurs du secondaire ils avaient 24
heures d'enseignement sur les pratiques
numériques dans lesquelles on leur
demandait de partir de leur propre
connaissance vous voyez le
la contradiction même c'est à dire ce
sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
forcément les connaissances et on leur
demande de partir de leurs connaissances
24 heures c'est très peu
ce que moi j'observe aussi sur le
terrain c'est que les éducateurs sont
assez en face à l'ampleur de des sujets
à l'ampleur aussi du travail qu'ils ont
sur le terrain parce que il s'agit pas
que de repérer des enfants ou des ados
qui sont sur les réseaux sociaux sujets
aux images pornographiques etc il faut
aussi les évaluer les former enfin leur
les former à la vie sociale enfin bon
c'est beaucoup et on leur demande en
plus de faire attention aux risques des
réseaux sociaux moi ce que je ce que je
préconise et je pense que mes collègues
sont d'accord c'est et ça rebondit sur
la notion d'image et de puissance des
images c'est à dire une il faudrait dès
la maternelle dès qu'on a accès à un
livre dès qu'on a accès à des images
avoir un programme scolaire sur
l'éducation aux médias et à l'image
et sur ce programme scolaire d'éducation
médias et à l'image et bien amener les
enseignants à déployer l'esprit critique
à partir de l'âge de 3 ans c'est à dire
dès l'entrée à l'école maternelle
et si on arrive à mettre ça en place et
bien déjà on aura donné certaines armes
à nos enfants pour aborder ce contenu
qui est de plus en plus exponentielle
sur les réseaux sociaux et dont en effet
on ne pourra pas
voilà
contraindre
mobiliser autrement voilà en effet il y
a une puissance et il faut quand même
voilà dire qu'on a les moyens partir du
carnet de santé moi je trouve que c'est
une très bonne idée la question c'est
combien de parents lisent c'est pas du
carnet de santé
mais
pas tous pas tous dans le sur le terrain
pas tous hélas en tout cas dans les
populations les plus précaires qui n'ont
pas forcément accès au langage qui ne
sont pas dans une insertion culturelle
et professionnelle importante et je
pense que c'est là aussi qu'il faut agir
autre rapport que j'ai corrigé avec le
ministère de la Culture et de la
Communication qui était les effets des
actions de médiation et une culture sur
les enfants et les adolescents là aussi
c'est une approche c'est à dire déployer
dans
au sein de l'éducation nationale des
approches culturelles et artistiques qui
vont permettre aux adolescents de
prendre de la distance avec ces objets
là qui sont des objets culturels
n'oublions pas que les réseaux sociaux
sont des objets culturels donc il faut
proposer d'autres types d'objets
culturels pour pouvoir diversifier les
approches
voilà pour cette question qui embray sur
donc je vais répondre je sais plus qui
m'a posé les questions mais j'ai noté
les questions quelqu'un m'a posé la
question
autour de la terminologie entre
l'utilisation de Youtube et de ne pas
pouvoir s'en passer je ne la dans ce cas
de figure je n'ai fait que traduire et
reprendre la question qui a été posée
dans l'étude
dans le cadre de cette étude là cela
voulait simplement dire s'il fallait
renoncer
s'il peut fallait choisir une
application de réseau social auquel on
ne voulait pas renoncer quelle serait
l'application sociale choisie c'était ça
que ça voulait dire par ne pas pouvoir
s'en passer
ensuite
il y avait
quelque chose autour de l'investigation
des effets de corrélation ce sur quoi je
suis en total accord mais pour cela il
faut de un reconnaître qu'il y a des
effets de choléra corrélation qui
nécessite de continuer d'investiguer
là-dessus et que de deux du coup de
donner des moyens pour mener d'autres
recherches et de multiplier les actions
éducatives je pense que le monde
scientifique n'est pas en opposition
pour m'aimer ses recherches là
simplement il faut que il y a à la fois
une reconnaissance publique et que de
deux qui est les moyens qui suivent avec
on m'a posé la question on m'a posé la
question à moi je crois Tik Tok comment
identifier les enfants qui ont moins de
15 ans donc la base est assez simple
c'est quand on s'inscrit on doit noter
son sa date de naissance cela veut pas
dire que certainement pas dire que les
jeunes vont répondre finalement à leur
date de naissance parce que ceux qui se
passe sur TikTok aussi c'est que si vous
mettez une date de naissance qui est
inférieur à 13 ans le l'application vous
bloque et vous empêche de créer un
compte sur Tik Tok
c'est ça c'est du dépôt c'est ça
voilà excusez-moi
je il y avait quelque chose autour de
l'accroissement des inégalités
socio-économiques
sur quoi je suis également en accord
[Musique]
cela veut dire qu'il est encore plus
d'urgence en fait à venir en
accompagnement sur les familles qui sont
plus en difficulté parce que nous sommes
parce que nous comprenons que les
familles qui sont plus en difficulté qui
ont des situations plus spécifiques vont
peut-être avoir plus recours
statistiquement des réseaux sociaux
numériques et auquel cas si on les
laisse si on les considère comme égal à
d'autres familles de différentes classes
sociales
économiques ce serait un décalage de
traitement
il a été évoqué la question de aussi du
contrôle parental
il y a un loi qui a été passée récemment
avec un décret qui est en cours de
rédaction
nous ce qu'on constate c'est que le
contrôle parental n'est pas suffisamment
utilisé en France on est en moyenne un
peu moins de 4 familles sur 10 qui
installent un logiciel de contrôle
parental
avec aussi me semble-t-il et c'est ce
que j'avais dit lors des auditions avec
le député Studer c'était que derrière on
a aussi fait pendant très longtemps des
fausses promesses aux parents
dans les dans les précédentes plan de
déploiement de ces outils en leur
faisant croire qu'ils avaient entre les
mains la solution miracle capable de
pallier à toutes les situations qu'il
rencontrait or il n'en est rien
aujourd'hui un an un enfant normalement
constitué de 9 ans seront normalement
sur YouTube sur lequel il va tomber sur
un tutoriel fait par un enfant de 6 ans
qui va lui expliquer comment désactiver
le contrôle par ental que papa s'est
embêté installé tout le week-end donc ça
c'est la réalité
voilà c'est fou et donc en tout cas
en tout cas tout ça pour dire que ces
outils ont une utilité mais il faut
aussi être conscient et lucide quant à
leur limite technique et limite aussi
par rapport aux capacités des enfants à
trouver des solutions pour les parer
c'est pour ça que nous on a adopté à
l'Open un principe de réalité on dit aux
parents que globalement à partir du
moment où les enfants commencent à
atteindre l'âge de 10-11 ans ça devient
quand même quelque part ça crée un sacré
mythe l'utilité du contrôle parental
autre point qui a été évoqué
sur les préconisations j'ai pas rebondir
sur ce qui est angélique a répondu à vos
questions madame Boyer madame Morin de
saillie évidemment qu'on connaît très
bien ces rond évidemment qu'on travaille
ensemble si vous rendez sur notre site
vous trouverez des vidéos de prévention
qu'on a même fait avec lui donc c'est
quelqu'un qu'on apprécie et qu'on
respecte beaucoup pour autant si on fait
preuve de pragmatisme on regarde du
déploiement de la règle 3 6 9 12 qui
fait encore référence et qui est très
déployé partout en France il est vrai
que nous on constate sur le terrain et
le nous le lui avons dit il en est tout
à fait conscient puisque la règle a
aussi beaucoup évolué ces derniers ces
derniers temps que les pas mal de
parents rencontrent un sentiment de
difficultés dans son application avec
parfois aussi un sentiment de se sentir
enfermé dans des balises ou des règles
et c'est pas propre uniquement à son à
son dispositif c'est aussi vrai pour les
campagnes du CS enfin de l'art comme sur
le pas d'écran avant 3 ans dont on voit
bien qu'elles ne fonctionne pas parce
que les parents nous disent on se sent
enfermé et ce ne correspond pas un
principe de réalité de notre vie
quotidienne ce qui va me permettre de
faire le lien avec la question de
Laurence Rossignol sur l'accompagnement
et vous avez raison Laurence des des
des familles monoparentales il y en a de
plus en plus et évidemment l'idée n'est
absolument pas de culpabiliser ces
familles qui ont déjà beaucoup apporté
je vais vous donner un exemple concret
en effet en effet quand on anime des
groupes de paroles et que ou des
réunions avec des parents avec des
mamans ne disent bon bah vous êtes sympa
avec vos conseils mais moi comment je
fais avec mes trois enfants le matin
parce que j'ai pas forcément envie de me
lever à 5h du matin et on peut les
entendre et les comprendre on essaie
justement de les mettre
de trouver des situations qui
correspondent à leurs besoins sans
extraire les écrans mais en trouvant des
usages qui soient adéquats par exemple
ce que je dis souvent c'est maman
pourquoi ne pas enlever les images même
avec des enfants qui sont tout petits
utilisés un smartphone pour mettre des
petites chansons des petites comptines
sur une playlist Spotify ou autre qui va
permettre à l'enfant de de pas être en
contact avec des images d'être d'humeur
est avant d'aller à l'école le matin et
souvent les mamans rebondissent en
disant bah oui et d'ailleurs ça me
permettra de continuer à écouter les
chansons avec dans la voiture pour
l'emmener à l'école et on pourra chanter
tous ensemble donc il y a aussi des
moyens aujourd'hui de donner des
conseils concrets à ces familles sans
les ostraciser en essayant de tenir
compte de leurs pratiques familiales et
nous c'est vraiment ce qu'on essaie de
porter tous ensemble à l'Open c'est à
dire de d'être vraiment dans le
pragmatisme des familles et des
difficultés qu'elles rencontres sans
nier évidemment les problématiques et
les questionnements posent ces outils
sans nier la réalité de certaines
connaissances de nos scientifiques mais
on ne sait pas tout et il est vrai que
notamment sur les effets de corrélation
et c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
et ça a été redit par Milan bien sûr que
ça doit ça doit permettre de d'engager
des recherches et de susciter des
réflexions par rapport à certaines
observations mais pour autant il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui dans le débat public
et par le biais souvent de personnes qui
ont envie de vendre des livres ou des
conférences à 1000 euros on observe
aussi
une espèce de panique morale qui a
entretenu par pas mal de personnes qui
s'auto improvisent experts de ces sujets
voilà mais même des médecins des
médecins de PMI qui répandent partout
des choses qui font beaucoup de dégâts
sur le terrain et et qui n'apporte pas
de solution assez familles or il a été
bien dit et vous l'avez tous remarqué
quand en effet sur ces questions là il y
a énormément de pièces aussi économiques
on le sait les études de l'Inserm nous
le montrent la cohorte elfe qui est une
cohort longitudinale et je rejoins ce
que disait mille ans pour répondre à
toutes vos questions de manière
collégiale il faut vraiment soutenir la
recherche sur ces questions l'Inserm a
besoin d'argent la cote Elf aujourd'hui
dans les résultats qui nous publient
chaque année sur la question notamment
des écrans il y a un décalage à peu près
7 à 8 ans entre les données qui publient
et au moment où les ont été collectés
comment voulez-vous qu'on mette en place
des politiques publiques digne de ce nom
efficaces alors que on est complètement
en décalage de huit ans ce qui a
l'espace de l'écosystème du numérique et
abyssal abyssal donc il y a un besoin de
donner de l'argent aux chercheurs de
renforcer ces dispositifs pour permettre
que l'on colle à la réalité de ce que
vivent les familles et qu'on ne soit pas
sur des supputations qui souvent
engendrent panique moral et n'apporte
pas de solution y compris vers des
familles plus en difficulté
avec des familles qui du coup
s'informent eux-mêmes sur les réseaux
sociaux sur comment être parents
aujourd'hui et avec des débats quand
même très houleux entre parentalités
positives et autres machins et qui du
coup aussi met à mal et culpabilise
énormément les parents sur ces questions
et pour pour conclure bien sûr ça a été
dit l'éducation nationale il y a besoin
de repenser les choses sans montrer du
doigt la responsabilité des enseignants
bien sûr ils ont beaucoup à faire mais
aussi renforcer les programmes de
formation ça concerne aussi les
éducateurs oui le dispositif promeneur
du Net est un dispositif intéressant
nous qu'on avons une vision nationale la
problématique qu'on rencontre c'est
qu'il est très hétérogène en fonction de
des endroits où il est appliqué il y a
ça fonctionne très très bien parce qu'il
y a des moyens dans la compagnement à la
formation des professionnels des
professionnels qui ont été déployés et
d'autres au contraire où sa
dysfonctionne complètement donc il y a
besoin de renforcer les compétences des
professionnels et des parents sur ces
sujets parce que moi je le vois bien
quand on fait des formations vers les
professionnels on tombe toujours dans le
dans une vision très dichotomique des
choses avec soit des personnes qui sont
très techniciennes maîtrisent les outils
techniques à qui il manque complètement
les compétences psychosociales pour
accompagner les familles soit au
contraire des gens qui sont issus du
sang de la formation psychosociale et
des compétences psycho-sociales à qui il
manque les compétences techniques et
aujourd'hui l'urgence il est de
rejoindre ces deux champs là pour
permettre aux formateur aux adultes
d'être suffisamment équipés et répondre
à la compagnement important des enfants
et des adolescents sur sur ces sujets je
regarde si j'ai rien oublié il me semble
qu'on a à peu près balayé l'ensemble des
questions dans le dans le temps qui nous
étaient impartis il nous reste à vous
remercier comme j'ai pas posé de
questions je saisis l'occasion de
remercie simplement pour pointer le fait
que vous avez évoqué et ça vaudrait une
autre discussion en soi la question des
coachs parentalités enfin sur nos
détenant nos départements différents je
sais pas comment le ressentent les
collègues mais alors il y a une espèce
d'explosion tout le monde est coach en
parentalité
probablement que les enfants qu'on
adresse que les parents adressent vers
les cochons sont à peu près déjà sauvés
parce que si le parent a déjà l'idée de
s'adresser à quelqu'un encore il faut
qu'il soit la bonne personne il y a déjà
ça et les éléments que vous donnez
amènent à s'interroger sur la question
de l'aspect de service public de tout
cela et du bon moment aussi parce que si
dans les pays tout le monde n'est
peut-être pas formé pour
l'idée d'une systématisation à la PMI
avant l'arrivée de l'enfant et un moment
où il y a une proportion de gens qui
passent par la PMI d'une manière ou
d'une autre comment rendre cela
systématique ou obligatoire mais enfin
ce que vous évoquez est extrêmement
extrêmement intéressant et si vous
voulez en dire un mot allez-y oui je
rebondis juste parce que ça me ça me
parle particulièrement j'ai accouché il
y a quatre mois et donc j'ai fait ce
parcours de de maternité PMI et à aucun
moment que ce soit à la maternité alors
qu'on a des en effet des cours de
préparation à l'accouchement et puis de
retour à la maison et là ici justement
on est dans une période un peu bulle où
on pourrait
intervenir auprès des parents sur ces
questions et avant l'accouchement et
après quand on va à la PMI en effet là
pour le coup il y a vraiment rien qui
n'est fait on agit une fois qu'elle est
troubles chez l'enfant à la PMI vous
voyez même l'effet inverse puisque
aujourd'hui vous voyez des enfants
sortir de la maternité qui n'ont pas
croisé le regard de leur maman
puisque le seul regard qu'ils ont pu
croiser en quatre jours c'est la
lentille du smartphone pour pouvoir
alimenter le WhatsApp familial ça c'est
une réalité et aujourd'hui il y a un
vrai besoin de sensibilisation y compris
dans des lieux comme cela pour non pas
une fois encore culpabiliser les parents
mais simplement les amener à réfléchir à
repenser leur pratique
à l'aune de cette de ces cette
génération cette généralisation pardon
de l'utilisation de ces outils dans le
smartphone fait partie
sociaux
on est même sur le vital
[Musique]
n'opposant pas les sujets nécessaires et
dernière remarques je vous remercie
d'avoir
je vous remercie d'avoir pointé du doigt
le le comment dire cette pratique
consistant aussi à venir donner des
leçons et des recommandations là-dessus
en se faisant payer très cher les
conférences mais probablement il y
a-t-il un tri facile à opérer c'est que
quand on vous demande une conférence
très chère sur le sujet c'est peut-être
pas ce qu'il y a de plus fondé derrière
et on connaît beaucoup de spécialistes
qui font qui viennent faire de
l'éducation populaire de manière tout à
fait
désintéressée voilà qui sont souvent pas
les plus mauvaises en l'occurrence